so part two of showing my sister crushes  that me and my friends had in the early  2000s and seeing what she thinks of them  today smash your pass  okay this what smash oh okay okay what  about him  pass pass smash  these are some quick answers for some of  them weird smash  smash yeah yeah he was you know where  he's from  isn't he from high school musical no  um  what's it called  god you know it  it's mean girls  is it mean girl yeah it's the guy in you  knows too google  okay  um  come on  he's so [ __ ] smash your ass pass he  was like the it guy of like the early  2000s  pass really ashton kutcher yeah what's  that picture oh my gosh  okay this is  this is us here  okay  pass pass  why  why pass yeah why look at the way he's  standing his his tongue's out  so if he's people who constantly have  their tongues out in photos or red flags  oh okay fair enough